serial killers are high profile ones
they're cunning
controlling
or conniving
charming and they can be clever and it's
all about power and control they're
people like Eden Brady and Myra hinley
Fred and rosemary West
you've got these people at Tobin you've
got these people it's a challenge for
them to see if they can get away with it
and they all show similar traits
about power
the power of being able to take a life
away
about throttling someone binding them
watching them the victim took the last
breath where they can take their
ultimate
fantasy that they've got is taking a
life away and there's right through them
all they're all different
but the element there is the power
for them to be able to do it and it's
about control and that is a feature
in the serial killer types